（ショウ） 皆さん こんにちは！
しょーたろーです！
（液体をかき混ぜる音）
（ショウ）いや～ 暑い 暑すぎる！
まあ 夏なんで
しょうがないんですけども
皆さん
こんな暑い日 何しますか？
もちろん スライムプールですよね
でも！
ただのスライムプールじゃ
面白くない
というわけで 今日は！
こちらの冷え冷えスライ…
（チャイム）
も～っ！
なんだよ ホッシーかよ
（ホッシー）
なんだよって なんだよ
あっ もしかして撮影中だった？
真っ最中
あれ？ 今日からだっけ？
いや ビビるわ
昨日 確認したじゃん
（ショウ）ああ そっか 今日からか
（ホッシー）これ スライムか
はい 差し入れ
（ショウ）
うわっ デカプリンじゃん！サンキュー
今日から お世話になるからさ
（ショウ）もう 何でも協力するよ
（ホッシー）しかし なんだか
こじゃれた部屋だな～ クソー
（ショウ）
あれ？ 来たの初めてだっけ？
（ホッシー）うん
じゃあ 始めます
（ショウ） ああ ホッシーってさ
「TINE」って知ってる？
（ホッシー）
え？ なに？
あ～ 「TINE」
アメリカのさ
有名な人が載る雑誌なんだけど
なんか それのね
表紙に載る話が来てた
（ホッシー）え？ ショウに？
さっき 事務所の人から
メールが来てて
（ホッシー）すごくない？
（ホッシー）
しょーたろー 24歳
大人気ユーチューバー
現在 彼が運営する
ＳＨＯＷチャンネルは
日本一のチャンネル
登録者数を誇る
その投稿動画は常に
百万再生されるほどの
アイドル的人気だ
ツイッターの
フォロワー数は
有吉弘行
きゃりーぱみゅぱみゅ
孫正義などと並び
トップ10入りしている
なんと
地震速報よりも上位だ
そして
彼は高校時代からの
僕の友人だ
学園祭で一緒に
映画を作ったこともある
ずっと撮ってるね
こんな普通の風景撮っても
意味なくない？
（ホッシー） 知らないね
ドキュメンタリーってさ
かなり素材を多く撮って
編集でまとめるんだよ
（ショウ）へえ～
（ホッシー）「情熱大陸」なんて
半年追いかけるのザラらしいから
（ショウ）
あ～ 聞いたことあるかも
（ホッシー）
あっ ちょっと 先行ってて
（ショウ）え？
（ホッシー） 忘れないうちに
全景映像 撮影しとくからさ
（ショウ）家 撮るんだったら
モザイクかけてもらっていい？
（ホッシー）え？ いる？
（ショウ）いや だって
ホッシーのそれだってさ
（ショウ）誰が見るか 分か…
（ホッシー）静かに
（ホッシー）今 音も撮ってるから
（ショウ）ハッ 音？
ちょっと ホッシー 行こう！
（ホッシー） ちょっと 入ってる 入ってる
ちょっと 撮ってるから
（ショウ）ヤバい ヤバい
（ホッシー）えっ なに なに？
（ショウ）ヤバいヤツがいる！
（ホッシー）なんだよ なに？
（ホッシー）
あっ 何か来てる 何か来てる！何だ あれ？
（ショウ）モト子だよ！
（ホッシー）えっ？
（ショウ）モト子！
（ホッシー）あれ？ ショウ？
（荒い息）
（ホッシー）あっ！
（ショウ）大丈夫？
ホッシー ホッシー
ホッシー こっちこっち
大丈夫？
（ホッシー）何だよ あれ？
（ショウ）ストーカーだよ
（ホッシー）ストーカー？
（ショウ）
動画の背景とかを分析してさ
特定してくる子がいるんだよ
（ホッシー）特定厨ってヤツ？
（ショウ）それそれ
（ホッシー）マジか？
怖え～
（モト子）
ハア ハア… もう少しだったのに
どこへ行ったの しょーたろー様
ああ！
もう あいつ 誰なの？
一緒にいた
さといもみたいな顔のヤツ！
（ホッシー）そういうの いいから
何だ これ？
あっ これは… あれか
動画用か
なんか 他の部屋
すごい散らかってるね
ああ 動画で使った物
毎日 投稿してたら
片づける暇がなくってさ
（ホッシー） 動画って
毎日 投稿してるんだっけ？
（ショウ）うん
（ホッシー）
“うん”って さらっと言ったけど
じゃあ 休みは？
あ～ ないね
（ホッシー） え？
ユーチューバーって年中無休なの？
いや でも みんなではないよ
再生数 多い人は
ほぼ毎日やってるかな
（ホッシー）へえ～
いきます
皆さん こんにちは
しょーたろーです
皆さん
あめ玉 なめたことありますか？
今回は電動ドライバーの先の
あめっだまを…
今回は電動ドライバーの先に
あめ玉を付けて！
なめていこうと思います
スリー ツー ワン
あ～ ちょっ ちょっ ちょっ…
ダメ ダメ
痛いよ！
でも 意外といける気がしてきた
（うめき声）
ヤバい 前歯が…
次 とうもろこしを
ちょっと
食べてみようと思います
（叫び声）
前歯が！
歯みがきします！
あ～ 痛ぇ！
え？ だって 普通に痛い
え～っと
文明の利器 最高！
バイバイ！
（ホッシー）
忙しいところ すいません
いい？ 今
（ショウ）あ～ うん
（ホッシー）動画を作ってて
いちばん苦労する点は何ですか？
（ショウ）え～？
ああ…
ごめん ちょっと邪魔
（ホッシー）失敬！
（ショウ）よし 出来た
（ホッシー）おっ！
完成した？
（ショウ）うん とりあえずは
（ホッシー） これが ショウの動画が
アップロードされる瞬間ですね
ここから ショウの動画は
世界に配信されると
あれ？ どうしたの？
止めた？
（ショウ）ちょっと これ やめるわ
（ホッシー）えっ どうして？
（ショウ）これ よく考えたらさ
電動ドライバーじゃん
子供たちが見たらヤバいかなって
（ホッシー）
そういう理由でやめることあるんだ
（ショウ） 昔だったら
アップしてたかもしれないけどね
（ホッシー）
すげえ面白かったのに…
そのかばんはさ 何が入ってるの？
ああ 見る？
いや いつどこで面白いことが
起きるか分かんないからさ
（ママ）あれ？ しょーたろー？
（ショウ）ああ はい
すごい～！
握手してもらおう
こんにちは
いつも見てます
（ママ）ほら あんたも
（中学生）いいよ
（ママ）あの 写真 いいですか？
（ショウ）あっ もう ぜひ ぜひ
（ママ）はい チーズ
（シャッター音）
（ママ）ほら あんたも早く
（中学生）
もう しょーたろーとかダサいじゃん
（ママ） 何言ってるの？
あんた 好きだったじゃない
（中学生） いや 昔は面白くて見てたけど
今は つまらないから見てないし
（ママ）え～？ そうなの？
（ママ）あっ ごめんなさいね
（ショウ）いえ いえ
（中学生）
もう しょーたろーとかオワコンじゃん
ありがとうございました
（小学生）バイバイ しょーたろー
（ショウ）バイバーイ
（ホッシー）
安心して 今のは使わないから
え？ 使っていいよ
よし
皆さん こんばんは
しょーたろーです
今日はですね
高校時代からの友人の
ホッシーと 一緒に
八王子の…
（ホッシー）
ごめん ごめん ごめんちょっと待って
え？ これ マジで動画にすんの？
（ショウ）いや もう回ってるから
（トーコ）え？
皆さん こんばんは
しょーたろーです！
今日はですね
高校時代からの友人のホッシー
（ホッシー） ちょっと待って
俺 出るのはカンベンだわ
（ショウ）いや いいじゃん
ホッシーの卒業制作
手伝ってんだから
（ホッシー）
そりゃ そうなんだけどいやいや…
皆さん こんばんは
しょーたろーと…
どうも ホッシーです
はい　というわけで 今日は
高校時代からの友人の
ホッシーと 一緒に
心霊スポット
行きたいと思います！
え～ ただいまの時刻が
なんと もう22時
（トーコ） ちょっといいですか？
これ 回ってます？
（ショウ）ああ 回ってます
（ホッシー）もう 回ってるから
（トーコ）
いや 私 今 スッピンだし
（ホッシー）
大丈夫だよお前 かわいいよ
（トーコ） いや もう
そういうの いらないから！
運転してるんだからさ ちゃんと
（ホッシー）じゃあ 俺がしようか
（トーコ）いや 免停じゃん！
（ホッシー）
そうなんだよ 免停なんだよ
（トーコ）ムカつく
一体 これは何ですか？
（ホッシー）
あの～ ユーチューバーの…
（ショウ）ユーチューブ
（トーコ） ユーチューバー
本当にいるんですね？
（ホッシー） いるよ お前
ツチノコじゃねえんだから
（ショウ）
トーコさんのことも前から
お兄ちゃんから
聞いてるんで
（トーコ）
あっ そうなんですね
（ショウ）どうか
よろしくお願いします
ユーチューバーってのは
趣味なんですか？
（ホッシー）そう思う人いるよね
（ショウ）うん まあ よくいる
（ホッシー）
ちゃんと仕事になってるんだよ
すごいんだよ 彼
日本一 ユーチューブ登録者数を
誇るんだよね？
（ショウ）うん まあ 一応ね
（トーコ）あっ そうなんですね？
あんま見ないんから
分かないんですけど
（ホッシー）
まあ とりあえず行きますか
（ショウ）
うん そうですねお願いします
はい というわけで 今日は
ホッシーの妹さんの
トーコさんに運転していただいて
心霊スポットに行こうと思います
よろしくお願いします
え～ 八王子の
元都立常磐高校
という場所に
行こうと思います
ここはですね
終戦の昭和20年まで
旧陸軍の研究所が
あったという場所で
かつて捕虜を使った―
人体実験が
行われていました
今も夜な夜な
実験被害者になった
人々の
悲鳴が聞こえてきます
そしてですね
校舎の４階にある
トイレの壁には
鏡文字で大量の
落書きがされています
鏡文字っていうのが
この 鏡に映すと
ちゃんと見える
文字のことですね
さらに
その鏡に向かって
“お前は誰だ？”
と13回唱えると
鏡の向こうに なんと…
霊が写る！
とされているらしいです
（ショウ） はい　というわけで
辺りが 少しずつ寂しくなってきました
多分 そろそろ
ラストコンビニなんですけれども
どうだ？
ああ あれかな 多分
右側に見えるのが
ラストコンビニです！
（ラジオ:ＤＪ）
そしたらね 突然 外から“ぎぃ～ ぎぃ～”と
何やら 恐ろしい音が
聞こえてきましてね
そのとき 橋の真ん中に…
（ホッシー）わっ！
（トーコ）うわっ うわ～！
（ラジオ:ＤＪ）
髪の長～い女性が…
（ショウ）ナイス リアクション！
（トーコ）ホント ムカつく
（ホッシー）大成功だね
（ショウ）よかった
（ホッシー）何か食う？
（ショウ）
そう これを買ったんですよ
ジューシー焼きうどんパン
（トーコ）いや いらない
（ホッシー）
焼きそばパンじゃないの？
（ショウ）焼きうどんパン
（ホッシー）
ちょっと トイレって…
（トーコ）
え？ コンビニで行ってないの？
（ショウ）何 飲んだの？
（ホッシー）コーヒー牛乳
ちょっと ないかな？ 何か…
（ショウ）本当に漏れそうなの？
（ホッシー）うん
（ショウ）はい
（ホッシー）いや いや いや
はい　というわけで
元都立常磐高校に着きました
（ショウ）
ホッシーさんどうですか？
（ホッシー）
これは… ヤバい
というわけで 早速
霊の出るトイレに
侵入していきたいと思います
カモン
ホッシー 大丈夫？
（ホッシー）
うん ちょっと やっぱ漏れそう
（ショウ）
ちょうどいいじゃん トイレで
じゃ 入っていきます
（ショウ）
失礼しま～す
教室ですね
入りますか？
失礼しま～す
うっわ～
ほこりがすごい
あっあっ えっ？
スッポンだ
すごい
（ホッシー）
えっ てか… トイレあるじゃん
（ショウ）
うん！ これが うわさの…
（ホッシー）違うでしょ
（ショウ）毛の落書きが
（ホッシー）え？
（ショウ）ありますね
（物音）
（ホッシー）あっ びっくりした！
えっ！ なに なに？
びっくりした… え？
ちょっと もう帰ろうぜ
ヤバいって
（ショウ）まだまだ
まだいける まだいける
物が落ちただけでしょ
（ホッシー）ちょっと 俺 もう
ションベン 今 ちょっと出ちゃ…
（ショウ）“希望”
（ホッシー）“希望”
（ショウ）すごい凝ってるな
はい　というわけで
４階に着きました
確か この階だったよね
（ホッシー）うん
多分 これですよね
（ホッシー）うわっ これだ
開けましょうか
（ホッシー）
あっ 乗り憑られた
（ショウ）開けます
（ドアが開く音）
（ホッシー）え？
（ショウ･ホッシー）
うわ うわ うわ うわ…
（ホッシー）
え？ ホラー映画じゃん
（ショウ）鏡！ 鏡 鏡 鏡…
（ホッシー）あっ これか
じゃあ 入りますね
ちゃんと ついてきてね
じゃあ 早速
書いてみようと思います
（ショウ）書きます
（ホッシー）はい
（ショウ）“誰”
“だ”
では…
鏡に向かって
13回 言ってみます
“お前は 誰だ”
（ホッシー）何も起きないね
（ショウ）うん
いや～ 怖かったね
（ホッシー）
うん まあ それなりにね
（ショウ）は？ なんか“ホラー
映画だ”みたいなこと言ってたじゃん！
（ホッシー）ちょっと ジョージ･
Ａ･ロメロぽかったけどね
（ショウ）
エロエロ ジョージ メロ… 誰 誰？
（ショウ）待って ホッシーさん
（ホッシー）ん？
トイレ まだ行ってなくない？
ちょっと トイレ行こうよ
（ホッシー）いい いい！
（ショウ）行こう 行こう 行こう！
いいじゃん いいじゃん
そこにあるからさ １階にさ
早く
（ホッシー）わ～ マジかよ
（ショウ）フフフ…
（ホッシー）いや～
（トーコ）出たんですか？ 幽霊
（ショウ）いや
（トーコ）ですよね
（ショウ）まあ でも大体
いつもこんな感じだからね
（トーコ）
でも投稿するんですよね？
（ショウ）
うん そこは 編集でなんとか
（ホッシー）こういうのって 成功した
とかしないとか関係ないんだよ な？
（ショウ）
うん 行くことが大事なので
（ホッシー）
じゃあ ショウ こっちもいい？
（ショウ）はい
（ホッシー） え～ 今日の
動画の感想お願いします
（ショウ） え～ 今日行った
心霊スポットは 今まででも結構上位の…
（トーコ）あの！
ごめんなさい
ちょっといいですか？
（ショウ）はい
（トーコ）おかしくないですか？
（ショウ）何が？
（トーコ）
いや 今 何時だと思います？
２時半です 平日の
私 明日 ダンスの練習だって
言いましたよね？
（ホッシー）
ごめんって 俺が悪かった
（トーコ）お兄ちゃんは黙ってて
ユーチューバーだかなんだか
知らないですけど
ショウさん 普通の人 巻き込んで
非常識だと思いますよ
（ホッシー）
俺が車貸すって言ったの
（トーコ）免停なのに？
でも それをアップして
仕事にするのは
ショウさんですよね？
（ホッシー）俺も 卒制
手伝ってもらってるからさ
（トーコ）
友達なのは分かりますけど
あなたに影響されて
お兄ちゃん いまだに
“将来 映画監督になる”
とかまだ言ってるし
そういうの 才能なきゃ
できないに決まってんのに
（ホッシー）何 あれ？
（トーコ）えっ なに？
（ショウ）え？
（ホッシー）
なんか屋上に人がいるんだけど！
（ショウ）屋上？
（ホッシー）何 あれ？
（ショウ）自殺？
ホッシー 行こう
（トーコ）えっ なに？
ちょっと ヤバくない？
（ホッシー）なに なに？
（ショウ）やっぱり
（ホッシー）いやいや…
（ショウ）止めよう！
（ホッシー）え？
（人影）あれ？
ひょっとして
しょーたろーさんですか？
（ショウ）え？
ああ はい
あの！
（人影）やっぱり
僕 あなたの大ファンなんですよ
え？
（ショウ）ああ… はい
（ホッシー）え？
（人影）しょーたろーさん
ユーチューバーって…
楽しいですか？
あの…
ちゃんと撮っといてくださいね
（ホッシー）あっ…
（地面に落ちた音）